queen back at work welcoming two new
ambassadors to the uk albeit remotely
yet hours later the palace released
their statement the queen will not be
going to cop26
following advice the queen has been
undertaking light duties at windsor
castle they said her majesty has
regretfully decided that she will no
longer travel to glasgow to attend the
evening reception of cop26 her majesty
is disappointed not to attend the
reception
it was the news we were waiting for
after she pulled out of a trip to
northern ireland last week the palace
later confirming the 95 year old has
spent a night in hospital and had
preliminary tests for what we haven't
been told
the queen enjoys her work and she's been
at it a long time and i think seeing the
fruition of this moment and opportunity
in the world is important to her but
she's not superwoman and she's also not
immortal
and she's had the advice of doctors
after a bit of a setback to take it easy
and i don't think there's anybody among
us who would expect someone who's 95
approaching nearly 70 years of her reign
to do this enormous journey up to
scotland
october has been very busy for the
monarch a time when she has already done
her bit to push the importance of the
climate conference
at the opening of the scottish
parliament
next month
i will be attending cop 26 events in
glasgow
the eyes of the world will be on the
united kingdom
and at the welsh parliament unexpectedly
showing her frustration about other
world leaders
now it'll be up to prince charles and
prince william to play host two men
who've more than shown their own
commitment to the climate debate
so it would be wonderful if the queen
could be there because she's very much a
kind of respected public figure and we
know that those public figures are
really important for transmitting
messages around climate action and
really motivating and empowering people
to act but if there are other members of
the royal family there such as prince
charles and prince william that will be
you know absolutely fantastic we know
that people also really respect them and
they could really send the message
around the importance of climate action
the queen always modest has got used to
being center of attention over the years
again at cop she was going to be the
star of proceedings we're told she
doesn't want her absence to be an excuse
for others not to turn up